we're asked do the points on the graph
below represent a function now before
even attempting to do this problem let's
just remind ourselves what they mean by
a function a function literally just
takes some input and it's usually kind
of considered x some number x but it
takes some input let me do it in a
darker color so it takes some input
let's call it x and then it puts it into
it does something on it or it maps it to
another value so you take your function
your function takes x as an input and
then it outputs
it outputs a unique value or it says i
don't know what to do with x if it
outputs a unique value that value is f
of x or another way to think about it
maybe we could say that value is y
and you could say that y
is equal to a function of x you give me
an x and then the function does what it
needs to do on the x and then it outputs
a y either way to visualize it this
function either has to say let me give
you a y and one unique y or it'll say
i'm undefined i don't know what to do
with that x a function cannot give you
two different y's for the same x that
would just make it hard to specify what
to map x to so when we when they ask us
do the points on the graph below
represent a function we just really have
to make sure that for every x value
there is only one y value that it is
being mapped to or for any x value that
is undefined for example at 6 they have
not defined and let's just let me label
the axes just to be careful this is the
x axis this is the y
or the y is equal to f of x-axis so if
you tried to put 6 into this proposed
function it's undefined they haven't
told us what y would be equal here
that's completely cool
over here if you put negative 1 in this
proposed function it produces 3. that's
cool so so far this looks like it could
represent a function if it did just
based on this point you would say that f
of negative one because the input is
negative one is equal to three cool so
far
now when x is equal to two
so this if our proposed function when
you input a two it'll output a negative
two seems reasonable so far you input a
three it'll output a two still
reasonable
now when x is equal to 4 if we want this
to be a function what this
what this graph is implying is if you
inputted
x is equal to 4 that the value of the
function or the proposed function
is both negative 1 and 5. so there this
is kind of saying that if you take 4
into our function
into our proposed function we can't
really call it a function yet we're
trying to see if we can call it a
function so if you put into a proposed
function that it would be
that it could get to negative one
and or or it could get to five and this
is just not allowed it is mapping the
value four to two values that is not
allowed for function a function has to
map from a value to only one other value
so this the graph the points on the
graph below do not represent a function
so i'll just write a
no here